this new game show is called the wall
and the producer is LeBron James he's
like main producer on the show yeah now
here's the question
you were famously proclaimed a
self-proclaimed nerd and here you are
working with LeBron James are you a
sports fan no at all and I didn't even
know when I met him I didn't even know
what to you know my mom was my mom's a
huge sports fan when I met LeBron I was
like hi good job bouncing the ball and
stuff like I don't know anything about
basketball my mom knew everything about
you know she started listing his his
whole sports resume and it was very you
know it was sweet because my mom my mine
don't call it a resume ever it is I
don't I'll go on to LeBrons LinkedIn
profile I'll get all details but my mom
is such a rabid sports fan like I have
the earliest memories of my parents
watching sports and just like swearing
at the team my mom is @nerdist mom on
Twitter she live tweet sporting event
swears like a sailor and I was coming
home on Saturday to go do my Batman
photo shoot and the ferret was raining
very hard which is difficult in Los
Angeles because we think that means the
apocalypse yes scandal yeah
which it kind of does it kind of does
yeah exactly and so it's raining really
hard outside I call my mom okay I just
landed from San Francisco milk and she's
like oh that's okay sweetie I know
what's raining over there what are you
doing there Aaron Rodgers the defense's
give well why don't you just do some
foreplay if you're just gonna give like
that
clearly clearly she's watching the game
and you don't know that no I was a
horribly drawing I'm like this one would
break in like I didn't know what's
happening right why did someone break
into our home and start sexually
attacking Rogers you know it's a strange
time gorilla porn
you okay are there football players in
your living room floor that's right I
can't see anything
you